Unfortunately, the baby monkeys did not develop well socially. In fact, they
were aggressive, anti-social, and if they did become parents themselves, they
were abusive to their offspring. These monkeys did not have any role models to
teach them how to parent or how to interact with other monkeys.
&gt;&gt; That's right. And that's why Harlow's research was criticized so much by
ethical groups.
&gt;&gt; Although it was completely legal in the time before the Animal Welfare Act told
us we had to treat animals ethically.
&gt;&gt; However, it does demonstrate an important part about development. It reinforces
the idea that we are social creatures and we need to have interactions for
aappropriate development.